Hannah is in Georgia as my husband and I
are on baby step 3b now what that means
is that they are debt free except their
home they've saved up their emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and 3b means beyond that they're saving
for the downpayment on their house we
want to take our two young children to
Disneyworld
you should we're currently saving to
build our own new home on property we
bought in cash already we can cashflow
the trip by not saving for the house for
one month about three thousand dollars I
feel guilty for both not taking a family
vacation and for not saving the money
where's the balance you're guilty a lot
aren't you I mean you're stuck because
you're just gonna be guilty you're
guilty if you go to Disney they're gonna
be guilty if you don't you know what I
do I'd be happy if I did either one not
gonna be guilty either way it's your
money it's your choice you're smart
either way you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund and you're saving up
for expenditures one of the expenditures
is you want to build a house for cash
that's an awesome goal second one is you
want to spend one month of that money
and go to Disney about 3,000 bucks
either one is wonderful you should not
feel guilty either way but I'll tell you
what I would do I'd go to Disney yeah
little kids you part it's perfect age
for that if you hit something you
obviously do want to do something they
want to do it's not something I want to
do but you it's fine I mean Rachel
Cruise loves Disney she just took her
little baby down there they had a
wonderful time not sure how great a time
her husband had but they had a great
time and no but I mean if it's what you
want to do you've saved up the money
you're not going into debt you're not
getting out of debt and going on
vacation you're out of that you have
your emergency fund this is the point in
the baby steps where you enjoy some of
the money and I don't suggest consuming
all of it and hitting no long-term goals
but I think if you don't consume some of
it and only hit long-term goals then
you're not enjoying your life you live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else
during the first three baby steps you're
extremely intense you don't do anything
except beans and rice
and beans to you out of debt and have
your emergency fund in place then you
let your foot off the accelerator some
to where you can do baby steps for five
and six and purchases are in there all
at the same time baby step four it's 15%
of your income going into retirement
meanwhile you start putting some for
your kids college and five and six is
when you find extra money pay off the
house early in that sense that's what
you're working towards in the middle of
all of that we don't go ten years and
never go on vacation that's when you'd
go on vacation we don't go ten years and
never upgrade the couch that Springs
sticking out of it that's when you'd
upgrade the couch you just pay cash for
the stuff and you realize that every
time we consume something it slows down
our long-term wealth building but the
purpose of long-term wealth building is
to be able to consume and to be able to
give money piled up just for piling
having a pile of money's sake is not
worth anything it's only worth something
when it does something for your family
or you're able to do something for
others that's all it's good for